we're going to move on we are taking
phone calls here 617 830 4750 is the
number who's next on the phone hello my
name is Grover longer Genia great to
hear from you what's on your mind key I
just found partially one question um
I've been actually watching them a big
fan of you think it like really big fun
of you I I would like an out of luck for
you uh by the question is do you think
if you are Democrats are gonna keep on
going I to being fell out that are so I
can barely hear you Grover I'm doing my
best I think the question is whether
Democrats are going to continue being
sellouts is that the question yet okay
yet I think that unless there is a
significant change of direction in terms
of the Democratic Party understanding
that the sort of center left center
right thing and the DNC functioning
basically just as a corporation rather
than add advocates at advocacy group for
progressive uh elected officials it's
not going to be good for Democrats now
the Louisiana troll called in the other
day Patton said Democrats will never win
a national election it's pretty common
that one party wins one or two
presidential elections and then the
other party wins one or two presidential
elections it's been like this for a very
long time going all the way back to
nineteen thirty three which is the the
last period twenty year period when it
was all Democrats in the White House for
20 years but I do think that Democrats
need to get it together in terms of
figuring out that just playing the
centrist corporate status quo thing is
just not the path forward well I think
the concern now is that not only do we
not have the presidency we oh we have
nothing now and I think that more than
anything will cause a resurgence II from
the left and a rebranding of the DNC I
hope you're right I hope you're right
Grover I hope that answers the question
for you yes that's why your one last
quick question yeah do you think if
they're going to continue on this path
and the the order form a third party
candidates are going to take over
nothing Democrats are gonna be now two
parties yeah I've addressed that until
there's instant runoff vote
and a reform of how elections are
financed third parties nationally at
least you're gonna have a really really
hard time and I've done a few rants on
that which you can definitely check out
on our YouTube channel Grover thank you
so much for the call we're gonna move on
really hard time hearing Grover I don't
know about you pat it was just tough to
hear I don't know if it was about audio
levels or enunciation or what it was
that we got through he was just low but
I'm glad we were able to answer his
question